and at 6 48 St Patrick's Day is a week
from today but Henderson gets its party
started this weekend Never Too Soon all
the fun begins on Water Street Brian
will joining us live with a preview of
the parade and all the shenanigans hi
Brian
yeah top of the morning to you guys and
I am joined we are lucky enough today to
have Kathy and Cindy with us and we are
talking all about the festivities that
are happening this weekend so much going
on Sydney let's just talk us through
what is happening this weekend what can
we expect from this year's event well
we've got the carnival that we're on
right now
starts at 5
P Sunday we've got live bands we've got
a beer garden we have whiskey tasting we
have a St baldrick's shaving for charity
and everything we raised we put to
charity so
that is great to hear and Kathy the
saint baldrick's thing you're you're
heading that tell us a little bit about
that yes so Saint baldrig's if you're
not familiar with it is the foundation
for Childhood Cancer Research we are the
second largest
income producing fundraiser for
Childhood Cancer Research and we will
all of our proceeds and all of our tips
all of our posters from whiskey tasting
and we have a booth all day on Saturday
with lots of things going on so come on
out and donate some cash and what time
can we expect this to start tonight what
time can people start coming out here
five o'clock tonight till 10 and then
tomorrow at 10 A.M the parade starts and
it goes till 10 p.m and then Sunday at
noon to 4. awesome so much going on and
Kyle's gonna start the ride for us we're
gonna check it out thank you for tuning
in guys we do have a special message for
John this morning though you ready
ladies happy birthday John
and we'll be back right after this
oh thanks guys thanks ladies appreciate
that well that looks like fun yeah thank
you